Statesman that is the American wing what
you'd say the American version of king's
men and you guys are all named after
beverages what is your name
it's Aquila your tequila yep and you get
to you get to use a rifle which I think
would be incredibly fun because you can
do all kinds of fun tricks when I was a
kid I had a toy rifle and I would just
spend hours alone without a girl playing
with which maybe the babe magnet I am
today but it must be fun to play with
that no it was I mean it's an epic like
Americana the rifleman yes one of the
duck honors the life things act yeah I
mean so I got to do the Chuck huh that's
so cool it's amazing yeah Jeff Bridges
your name is what is
I'm I'm I'm I like them pain what's that
champagne your champagne
give my name I don't live my name so I
made people call me champ champ that's
nice you didn't I assigned you champagne
you didn't like it see well actually
yeah
do you like champagne and real life you
don't hang over you yes we've all had a
champagne hangover it's not good it's
amazing you can't go anywhere without
people screaming dude is it it's just
your life I mean do you see he's wearing
jellies yeah are you
they're nothing if not comfortable
you